en france 24 es hora de hablar de
economía por ello en el estudio me
acompaña mi compañera daniela blandón
daniela bienvenida iniciamos con el plan
de infraestructura de joe biden aprobado
por el senado que incluye o la valentina
mire la cámara alta de eeuu aprobó un
plan bipartidista de poco más de un
billón de dólares que según la casa
blanca agregará en promedio 2 millones
de empleos por año durante la próxima
década ahora veamos que incluye el
proyecto de ley al que todavía le falta
el visto bueno de la cámara de
representantes- aporta casi 120 mil
millones de dólares para transporte
público ferrocarriles y vehículos
eléctricos otros 110 mil millones irán a
construir
173 millas 173 mil mejor millas de
carreteras y para reparar 45 mil puentes
en malas condiciones también lleva a 65
mil millones para garantizar acceso a
internet en áreas remotas del país y una
cifra igual para modernizar la red
a la infraestructura de agua potable le
fueron asignados 55 mil millones y con
25 mil millones adicionales se mejorarán
las pistas y torres de control de los
aeropuertos esto entre muchas otras
partidas de menor cantidad daniela y de
eeuu vamos a chile porque mineros del
norte del país van a huelga y hay otros
que amenazan con hacer lo mismo así es
valentina unos 300 trabajadores de la
minera caserones en la región norteña de
atacama iniciaron este martes una huelga
al no alcanzar acuerdos con la compañía
alúmina cooper que es subsidiaria de una
empresa japonesa al mismo tiempo los
empleados de la mina escondida que es el
mayor yacimiento privado de chile-
operado por la australiana bhp billiton
así como los de la estatal codelco
continúan negociando con sus respectivos
empleadores para evitar un cese de
actividades todo porque valentina porque
los mineros están reclamando reajustes
salariales y aumento de los bonos extra
legales en medio de un momento
excepcional en los precios del cobre
recordemos que en chile que concentra
una tercera parte de la producción
mundial de metal del metal rojo la
extracción de minerales supone más del
10 por ciento del pib daniela y se
profundiza la escasez de semiconductores
en la industria automotriz bueno hay un
brote de kobe 19 en malasia que es uno
de los grandes productores y esto
empeoró la escasez de chips que ha
obstaculizado la producción de vehículos
en el mundo desde finales del año pasado
por ejemplo la japonesa nissan anunció
un cierre de dos semanas de su enorme
fábrica estadounidense en tennessee se
trata de una de las mayores parálisis de
la industria automotriz en ese país
desde que inició la crisis de
semiconductores y afecta a unos 6 mil
700 empleados sólo en esta planta otras
empresas también padecen la misma
situación general motors suspendió
temporalmente su producción en tres
plantas y esto sumado al aumento de la
demanda ha hecho que por supuesto se
disparen los precios de los vehículos
nuevos e incluso ya llegó también a las
usadas bueno daniela pues bastante grave
hablamos de otro tema y es que en
camerún se ve amenazada la producción de
cacao por la extrema sequía
porque este es el país el cuarto
productor de cacao más grande de áfrica
valentina después de costa de marfil
ghana y nigeria que le llevan a una gran
ventaja hoy enfrenta una dura batalla
para cumplir su objetivo a largo plazo
de subir la producción anual de cacao
más allá de las 300.000 toneladas de hoy
en día esto debido a las amplias
temporadas de sequía
debe existir
ha habido cuatro meses de sequía aquí se
ve todo está chamuscado es tener una
plantación productiva ahora todo está
quemado tres hectáreas destrozadas por
la sequía eso se debe a que la temporada
seca duró más de seis meses a quien
tenga por eso no tenemos suficiente
cacao en este momento y le agrego de
áfrica occidental y central proviene
alrededor del 70% de los granos de cacao
del mundo y lo grave es que de ahí viene
el chocolate valentín así que calcule
daniela bastante complicado vamos con
los indicadores de la jornada bueno él
sí que le dio el senado al plan de
infraestructura impulsó a wall street a
un nuevo récord el martes al menos
entonces los índices dow jones y
standard and poor's en europa la racha
de récords sigue imparable y acumula
siete días de ascenso ayudada por los
excelentes resultados empresariales
sobre todo de compañías de viajes y ocio
y en américa latina la bolsa brasileña
cayó por culpa de la alta inflación y
por el turbulento clima político y
cerramos con la cifra del día 30 mil
millones de euros angela merkel anunció
este fondo para repararlos tras las
inundaciones que azotaron a alemania en
las últimas semanas daniela muchas
gracias a ustedes por su sintonía
continúen con nosotros